TV's biggest night is almost here now et
is here to help you throw an Emmy party
worthy of the stars that's right guys
the 70th annual Primetime Emmy Awards
are just around the corner so it's time
to text all of your friends and invite
them over for an Emmy viewing bash and
I'm going to make sure you wow them with
a menu inspired by this year's
Outstanding Drama nominees
first up pilgrim Rick's mini
Thanksgiving cheese dogs we are going to
skewer our hot dogs and then we're gonna
roast them on an open furnace flame and
then once they get all toasty and warm
we're gonna wrap it and cheese and then
roll it and crushed up crackers
Thanksgiving cheese dogs
is there any cuter family than the
Pierson family they give me all the
fields and Jack saloon okay anyway here
I have my take on Jack's makeshift
Motel Turkey Day feast sweet and spicy
pigs in a blanket with a habanero
cheddar cheese dip if you guys are
pressed for time just go ahead and go to
the frozen section of your local grocery
store they have pigs in a blanket there
by that go to your chip I'll get some
queso warm it up Hotel next up 11s mini
chicken and egg Oh waffles excuse me
young lady
you know you have to pay for
[Music]
[Music]
Nili Bobby Brown's character loves
frozen waffles like I love Chicago
deep-dish pizza with a fierce violent
passion channel your inner 11:00
sprucing up the classic breakfast treat
by stacking homemade waffles with pieces
of fried chicken breast sprinkle with
honey and parsley and top off with a
tiny pickle slice if you guys are in a
rush just toast those mini frozen
waffles and skewer them with cut-up
chicken tenders from your deli right
here we have Moroz truffle mac and
cheese you got coffee great you get
something to eat yes thank you you're
very welcome
it came on mac and cheese night lucky
Thursday is turkey Tetrazzini Laura made
it to Canada in season 2 and her freedom
was met with a classic macaroni and
cheese YUM that's the inspo for this
dish only I added Parmesan Swiss cheddar
and fontina cheese as well as a little
truffle oil to fancy it up if you want
to impress your guests serve it in these
teeny tiny too cute for words iron
skillets pressed for time
you can always spoon your favorite brand
of mac and cheese into these bad boys
and top it with some bread crumbs pop it
in the oven for a few minutes and voila
the next app inspired by one of this
year's Emmy nominated shows bison chili
bites
nothing says Wild West like an American
bison and chili am i right I'm loving
these bite-sized bison sweet potato
chili bites served in corn chip bowls
topped with all the fixings cheese sour
cream avocado tomatoes green onions
jalapeno and cilantro for a quick fix
guys just buy that chili in a can no
shame in that reheat game now it's time
to tuck some sweets here we have a very
regal moment the Queen's scones shall we
have tea
no high tea is complete without a scone
and Claire Foy I mean Queen Elizabeth
showed us how it's done during a
sit-down with Jackie O serve these with
homemade jam and clotted cream alongside
fresh berries or speed things up with
store-bought scones jam and creme
fraiche here we have an American apple
pie
we made stock ooh yeah it smells great
can't keep it around as Russian spies
living in the US Philip and Elizabeth
are living undercover and have to walk
talk and eat like Americans and nothing
says American like vodka just kidding
apple pie serve the homemade classic in
mini mason jars or in small pie dishes
or just pick up a full sized pie from
your favorite local bakery and last but
not least winter is here ice cream
winter is here
[Music]
well father always promised in me have a
little fun with this one take some red
velvet cake some vanilla bean ice cream
blend it together refreeze it and then
serve it to your friends for a treat
that's beyond the wall once all those
celebs have made their way down the red
carpet and it's time for the opening
monologue serve some chilled champagne
and play et SME bingo download the
printable bingo cards and markers in the
link below and have your guests keep
their eyes peeled for moments like an
ugly cry a wardrobe malfunction or a
golf clap alright guys I want to see
what you guys are cooking for your Emmy
party tag me in your pictures let's
start talking I want to hear all about
it and make sure you come back because
we're gonna have a how to throw a
Riverdale viewing party coming up next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]